everybody welcome welcome in to another
monday live stream uh we are kicking
this off i am dion robowen a reporter
for the wall street journal uh covering
markets and we're going to be talking
about everything going on
what you should be looking out for this
week in markets as well as looking back
a little bit at last week talking about
what the big events were and how they're
going to impact things not only this
week but going forward talking about
stocks bonds
oil commodities gold basically all the
big markets we're going to be getting
into all that and really what
we think all of you out there should be
looking out for and what i think you
should be looking out for this coming
week in terms of data and in terms of
market happenings and economic data
that's going to be coming out
the rest of the week so for this week
we've got a lot of data that i think is
going to play a big role in what we can
expect to hear from the federal reserve
in may and as we know central banks
drive markets so right now i think uh
the market is looking at three things
that's inflation inflation inflation and
this week is going to tell us a lot
about inflation so
thanks again for being with us here on
the live stream um we're going to be
trying this out for a little while we're
also going to be doing a bonus live
stream for you this week so i hope
you'll tune in for that as well but
going to get into it today i want to
talk through first of all what we can
expect this week and what you should be
looking out for um what then want to get
into what happened last week and how
that's affecting and moving markets
going forward so this week i think the
big release on the market calendar is
going to be that cpi number the consumer
price index that's going to tell us what
inflation has been
over the past month at the change in the
past month and it's going to tell us the
change over the last year
economists have an expectation for a
pretty large number we're going to dive
into that and and tell you just what
that means also we've got the ppi report
producer price index coming on wednesday
i'm going to tell you what that is why
it's important and how that relates to
what folks are going to be seeing on the
shelves and at the pump and all that
going forward
also we've got a like i said a big slate
of data not only consumer price index
and producer price index but u.s retail
sales that's coming out on wednesday and
the university of michigan's consumer
sentiment index coming out on thursday
so every day we get a new report that's
going to tell us i think i think
something very important about inflation
so i hope everyone will be tuning to
that i know i will be and we'll be
talking about what all that means at the
end of the week on friday uh just check
in let's look at the markets right now
on wsj.com looking at the dow down 0.6
percent right now the s p off 1.1
percent the nasdaq down one and a half
percent a rough morning on markets and
it doesn't seem to be getting that much
better as we move into the afternoon uh
the 10 year sitting at about 2.77
percent
really has moved up significantly over
the past week uh we've also got oil down
uh about four percent that's wti the u.s
grade brent crude down almost five
percent at 98 dollars a barrel we're
seeing some real significant moves there
and gold
up about
two percent so significant moves up uh
in gold we're seeing the market really
moving to start off this week
even though we haven't gotten a whole
lot of information so again we are here
we're doing this live stream i'm dion
robowen from the wall street journal
and i hope you'll join us every monday
as we talk through what to look for what
to look out for markets and look back at
the week that was before
so i want to jump into a report we got
today that i think wasn't really on a
lot of radars but i think it really
caught folks by surprise the numbers
that we got and that's that new york fed
survey of consumer inflation
expectations or it's gonna be the new
york fed survey of consumer expectations
the number that i think jumped out at
folks was the expect or the inflation
expectations rising to 6.6 percent over
the next year that means folks out there
expecting inflation to rise by 6.6
percent that is well above what the fed
has told us they expect inflation to be
uh the fed has said four point three
percent
so you're seeing a gap there between
what consumers say and what the fed says
of more than two percent which is the
fed's inflation goal so the expectations
for inflation
well above that but
differing from the fed's expectations by
more than two percent uh when you dig
into those details just want to get into
that really quickly
meeting expectations over a three year
period actually declined to 3.7 percent
largely because of folks who earn less
than 50 000 a year don't have a college
degree their expectations over a
three-year period declining
uncertainty though about inflation over
both one and three year periods rising
to a record high so folks saying we
expect prices to be higher we don't know
by how much but we we think that prices
are definitely going up and by a
significant amount i also want to point
to that year ahead household spending
expectations rising by 1.3 percentage
points now that's the highest increase
on record between surveys
meaning that folks saying from the last
time they were surveyed to this time we
expect inflation to rise by more than
one percent uh one point three percent
the highest level on record that's
that's a big number rising to seven
point seven percent that's also a record
high um so again thanks for being with
us on the live stream we're going to dig
into now all of what is coming for us
this week we got that survey from the
new york fed
uh i also want to point out really
quickly before we move forward the
number of consumers saying that credit
will be harder to obtain over the next
year uh rose above 50
that's the highest level ever on record
for the survey number of consumers
saying credit will be hard to get that's
very interesting because we really
haven't seen those rate hikes from the
federal reserve play into credit cards
and things like that because they've
only raised rates one time they're
projecting to raise rates a number of
times this year but the actual impact of
the fed's actions hasn't begun to hit
credit yet and we're already seeing more
than half of consumers surveyed say they
think over the next year credit will be
harder to get that's definitely
something to keep your eye on
since december we have seen a consistent
decline in expectations for household
income growth while we've seen a
consistent increase in expectations for
household spending when you break it
down households are saying look things
aren't good we expect to have to pay
more we expect to earn less and that's
why you've seen these consistent low
numbers for consumer sentiment consumer
confidence and things like that so as we
look forward to this week
must-see tv i think tuesday at 8 30 a.m
eastern time i don't know where you'll
be i'll be right here in front of this
computer looking at that cpi report uh
the consumer price index is expected to
show 8.4 percent increase year over year
in inflation 1.1 increase month over
month normally we talk about those
year-over-year numbers because this is
again projected to be the highest rate
of inflation in about 40 years but i
want to point to the month-over-month
number which is expected to be 1.1
percent that's gonna be some of the
highest inflation we've seen in years
when inflation starts to rise more than
one percent month over month you start
to get in some worrisome historical
comparisons um
if we beat this pace of 1.1 month over
month uh the projection we could start
to get towards the highest rate we've
seen since october
one point 2005
percent that was the second highest
reading all time for the cpi which dates
all the way back to the 1970s the
highest rate we saw month over month on
the cpi was 1.8 percent that was in
september 1973. i say all that to say
that we are starting to get back to
those 1970s levels potentially in terms
of the increase in inflation month over
month so that's definitely something to
watch out for like i said cpi
um 8 30 am on tuesday us eastern time
i i'll be watching the market will be
watching i hope you're watching
now a less followed report uh than cpi
is ppi the producer price index but i
think that's going to be big because ppi
in an inflationary environment sort of
signals where cpi is going to go so what
businesses are having to pay for their
labor for their inputs for commodities
things like that they have shown that
they are passing those prices onto
consumers so when you see an increase
last month in ppi of 10
well you can expect to see that cpi
consumer inflation rise this month
economists are expecting that we'll see
for march a 10.5 percent increase in ppi
so that shows that again inflation not
coming down not leveling off inflation
is rising and costs expected to continue
to rise for businesses continue to rise
for consumers we'll see if that number
comes in as expected if it does you can
probably expect to see inflation
continue to rise for consumers moving
forward
um be sure and check out if you're not
sure about that connection right like oh
well how does what businesses pay impact
consumers we did a video called why big
companies love inflation really kind of
sussing out that connection between
large companies and
rising prices and how that pushes higher
inflation a lot of people think
inflation is something that just happens
no people make inflation happen that's
ceos companies raising their prices that
boosts prices for what we pay on the cpi
consumer price index and raises
inflation so check that video out if you
have a second
a num another resort another report that
we'll be seeing this week u.s retail
sales that's coming out on thursday
and that's going to tell us how
consumers are reacting to higher prices
in february uh for in march we saw
february's report which said retail
sales increased 0.3 percent that was a
huge drop off from the january level of
4.9 percent uh economists are expecting
that to hold level at 0.3 percent
but
remember cpi inflation is rising is
expected to rise at 1.1 percent retail
sales expected to rise 0.3 percent
prices are rising at more than 1 percent
and sales aren't expected to rise at
even half that level that means
consumers are pulling back so the number
we get there will tell us okay
we know that consumers have a lot of
savings built up a great report from the
brookings institute came out a few weeks
ago that said consumers have
amassed an estimated 2.5 trillion
dollars in excess saving since march
2020 or between march 2020 january 2022
are they continuing to spend that
increase savings are they going out and
shopping or are they saying you know
prices are way too high for me i'm
staying home uh we're not going to go
out to eat this month we're not going to
go shopping we're not going to take our
trip to you know yellowstone or wherever
we're staying inside so i think that
retail sales report is going to be very
important um again i want to thank
everybody who's joined us on the live
stream for being with us i know you
could have been anywhere in the world
but you're here with me so i appreciate
that uh the other big thing next week
let's not forget the start of earning
season this i think relates to inflation
as well because it's going to tell us
what companies are doing about inflation
in that report why big companies love
inflation i talked about the you know
listing the company earnings calls and
telling them and them the ceos telling
all of us or the folks on the earnings
calls hey we are raising prices we are
taking advantage of this inflation and
increasing our prices and increasing our
bottom line we're going to find it if
we're going to hear that from these
companies this time around or if they're
going to say yeah inflation is really
kicking our butt we're not sure what to
do about it obviously they would phrase
things a little bit differently because
you want to make investors feel
confident about the stock but you know
how are they dealing with inflation what
are they doing and we're going to hear
next week or from this week excuse me
from jp morgan wells fargo citigroup a
lot of banks and financial companies
they are expecting to see a
year-over-year decline of 36 percent uh
in terms of earnings and that's largely
because they're putting a lot more money
away in terms of loan losses we saw this
uh when the pandemic hit the u.s and
started 2020
and it looks like we're seeing it again
it looks like banks are saying you know
what we're a little worried about the
economic environment we're putting a lot
of money away in terms of our loan
losses
so we'll see just how much that is and
just how much that weighs on earnings
factset broadly is expecting 4.7
earnings growth for the s p 500 uh
that's below historical trends and would
be the lowest since the fourth quarter
of 2020. so those big uh 2021 earnings
growth numbers that we saw look to be
kind of fading away and it's looking
like we're gonna start seeing more
moderated earnings growth but this is a
big but
despite everything we've got going on
inflation the war in ukraine
this coveted outbreak in china lots of
other things you have right now
more buy ratings from stock analysts on
the s p 500 on s p 500 companies
individual companies than we've seen at
any time in the last 10 years so despite
this kind of challenging environment for
companies and and for the economy
broadly
more buy ratings on companies within the
s p 500 than at any time in more than 10
years that's from my man john butters
over at factset so definitely something
to watch out for because analysts have a
pretty rosy outlook for the market even
though we've seen this kind of decline
we will also see on thursday the
university of michigan's consumer
sentiment index that'll tell us if
consumers are as rosy about the economy
and how things are going as stock
analysts are i think that's also going
to be a big report to watch out for so
that's what we've got coming up this
week again i want to thank all of you
all for being with us here on this live
stream we're talking through what to
look out for this week in the markets i
want to take a second and step back and
and look at last week but again i want
to thank you all for being with us here
on the live stream um because we are
talking about what you should be
watching and what i'll be watching
as it comes to and as it's you know as
we've gotten to this place where we are
right now in the markets
um if you watched the live stream last
week thank you for doing that um and
thank you for coming back but you
remember i talked to you about the two
big the two big important events that
were going to happen that was fed
governor leo brainard uh giving a speech
to the minneapolis fed and that was the
fomc minutes the fed's meeting minutes
coming out on wednesday well that bail
brainerd speech on tuesday moved markets
huge um not even you know it wasn't the
it wasn't a minor event markets i'm
going to tell you all about how big that
was but before that i want to talk about
this call for
recession um you know lots of people
talk about recession a lot you had the
yield curve inversion
and we saw last week two economists from
deutsche bank well-known bank uh they
have a good reputation on wall street
two of their top economists phd guys one
based in the u.s one based in europe say
in no uncertain terms we predict a
recession in 2023 for the u.s and we
expect a significant growth slowdown in
europe it's interesting because not even
a week before that note came out
barclays had a no doubt recession ha ha
april fools right well not even two
weeks later you have deutsche bank
saying yeah no we are calling for a
recession in 2023. they they note and i
want to read exactly what they said
quote our call for a recession in the
u.s next year is currently way out of
consensus
we expect it will not be so for long
we shall see we'll see that's uh
deutsche bank economist david folkertz
landau and peter hoop
given us that prediction based on the
war in ukraine being extended being
drawn out more than i think a lot of
folks expected and a quote elevated
buildup in momentum of inflation and
also expectations for what the federal
reserve is going to do about that
right now the market pricing in
about three percent rates three percent
interest rates from the fed by the end
of the year that is well above what the
federal reserve brought interest rates
to the last time they raised rates which
was just 2.5 percent and then if you
remember fed chair jerome powell did
that powell pivot which is kind of
famous in markets now reverse rates
started cutting rates and you know the
us economy couldn't even handle two and
a half percent
now the market is predicting that we'll
get to three percent before even the end
of the year and a lot of that had to do
with the speech that we got from fed
governor leil brainerd on tuesday
she really pointed to inflation-hurting
lower-income households and the reason
the market took such note of that was
because fed governor brainer is known as
a quote dove meaning that she prefers
keeping monetary policy loose keeping
rates low
doing more things like quantitative
easing to help out a lot of what she's
pointed at to as those lower income
households as black folks and hispanic
folks
folks who have historically been left
behind in recessions and and saying hey
you know we've got to keep rates low to
help those folks get jobs now she's
saying you know what flip that turn it
on its head we've gotta raise rates and
get inflation down to help those lower
income folks
um if you looked at the market that
speech was released at 10 am the the the
text of it was released before she even
started speaking the market hit 45 89 on
the s p 500 that was the highest that we
got we still haven't gotten back to that
level that was the highest since march
30th it crashed after that we have not
gotten back to that level since then and
it was clear that the market did not
like fed governor laelle brandon on what
she said not only was it about raising
interest rates she talked about the
balance sheet cutting down the balance
sheet the fed has amassed over these
past two years taking the balance sheet
from over 4 trillion to now almost 9
trillion dollars they're saying they're
going to start to let that run off as
soon as may fed governor brainerd said
they could start to let that roll off as
soon as may saying quote we are
committed to bringing inflation back
down to its 2 target recognizing that
stable low inflation is vital to
maintaining a strong economy and a labor
force that works for everyone so really
the same terminology that governor
brainard used about keeping rates low
and doing qe she's now using to talk
about why we need to raise rates and
that balance sheet runoff is key because
it adds more tightening it makes the
economy tighter it pulls that stimulus
out of the economy it pulls money out of
the economy and makes things harder
makes it harder to get credit makes it
harder to to buy things
that you know you need to get credit for
so again this speech by fed governor
brainerd was big last week it's what the
market watched and really reacted to and
we saw that so i want to thank you guys
again for joining the live stream and
for being with me here on youtube i'm
wsja markets reporter dion rabone for
those of you who tuned in and are like
who is this guy talking thank you for
being on my channel i appreciate that um
the other big piece of that puzzle last
week was the fomc minutes the minutes
from the feds meeting in march came out
last week on wednesday those told us
that yes not only
are we thinking about raising rates and
raising them faster than we were
previously we are looking at running off
our balance sheet reducing the amount of
bonds that we hold that's pushed money
out into the economy over these past two
years and reigning that back in
if you remember the fed's balance sheet
is now at about 8.9 trillion dollars
back in february 2021 it was about 4.12
or 4.17 trillion dollars so more than
double in just two years and if you
remember back in 2007 the fed didn't
even have 500 billion dollars on its
balance sheet we're now approaching nine
trillion dollars and it looks like that
balance sheet that has pumped so much
money out of the economy a lot of that
money that's gone into the stock market
gone into equities is going to now have
to be pulled back there's not going to
be more money pushed out to buy bonds
and in fact the fed is going to let
those bonds mature and roll off its
balance sheet that makes economic
conditions tighter and it's going to
make credit uh less affordable and and
things like that for consumers
their
the key term and the key term in those
fed minutes and the key term used by fed
governor lael brainerd it's been used by
jay pal
expeditiously we are going to
expeditiously start raising rates we are
expeditiously cutting down the balance
sheet we're doing these things faster we
are hitting the markets faster and
that's why i think you've seen this big
jump in in rates on the u.s interest
market the 10-year now at 2.77
that's why i think you're seeing bond
yields jump up and that's why i think
you're seeing this big sell-off in the
nasdaq down now one and a half percent
today to start out the week um they're
talking about doing 95 billion dollars
in runoff a month that's a cap that's a
maximum not a minimum but that's a lot
that's a big change from this
stimulative environment that we've seen
for a long time from the fed and they're
saying we're going to do this
expeditiously
i think that's that makes a big
difference because again a lot of stocks
in the market we saw as recently as last
year about 20 of large companies in the
s p 500 are unprofitable uh they are
zombie companies quote unquote which
means that they don't even earn enough
in profit to pay off the debt or pay off
the payments on the debt that they have
so when you're running a business like
that as about 20 percent of large u.s
companies are
it makes it hard when rates rise and it
gets more expensive to borrow money to
keep your business going now we haven't
seen that really start to hit businesses
yet we haven't seen a significant
increase in default rates on bonds and
things like that but as rates start to
climb that could be something that we
see in the market and that's not good
for the stock market obviously
and that's not good for the us economy
big businesses can't borrow as cheaply
which makes it harder for them to run
their business which adds cost and you
know slows down hiring slows down
profitability all those things really
mean are i'm sorry all those things are
what happens when the fed starts to
raise interest rates to make it really
simple
the fed wants those things to happen
that's why they're raising interest
rates because if you slow down the pace
at which people are spending money you
get them to stay home and you slow down
businesses borrowing you slow down the
economy businesses can't grow they can't
expand folks can't go out and buy the
things
like they were they can't buy a new
house they can't refinance and and take
money out to go spend on a vacation
those are intentional things the fed is
trying to do
when they raise rates so making sure
that you understand all that um when you
when we talk about the fed raising rates
and why that has such a major impact on
the u.s economy uh look so i am dion
rabone we are coming now to the end of
this live stream but thank you all so
much for being with us i want to check
in on the market one more time
as we look out we see oof things have
not gotten better the dow down about
0.75
s p 500 down about 1.25 percent and the
nasdaq down almost 1.6
right now so
remember we talked about it the start of
this live stream i said let's look at it
this week we get cpi consumer price
index what you and i what we're paying
at the store at the pump when we go out
to eat we're also going to get producer
price index uh what businesses are
paying for labor for inputs for
materials we're also going to get retail
sales what folks went out and spent
despite or because of inflation and then
we're going to get that university of
michigan consumer sentiment index on
thursday those are all coming out this
weekend i think those are all going to
tell us a lot about the economy and what
consumers and how consumers and
businesses are reacting to inflation
again fed governor leo brainard known as
a dove came out last week and said
inflation is our number one priority we
are going to whip that and get it down
we are also going to run off the balance
sheet which adds further tightening to
the economy
which makes it even harder to borrow
they said they're going to do that and
the fed minutes from march really came
and reinforced that so that's why we are
where we are with a 2.77 rate on the
10-year yield up more than 100 basis
points from where we were only about a
month and a half ago these moves have
been significant and i think there is
more significant movement to come so
stay tuned and i hope you like i will be
watching 8 30 a.m on tuesday cpi
um that number is going to be big
because it's going to really tell the
fed okay can we do we have to keep going
and keep saying that we are going to do
everything it takes to whip inflation or
can we ease off a little bit can we kind
of give consumers and businesses a bit
of hope that maybe we're not going to
raise at this very expeditious pace so i
hope you'll be watching i'll be watching
and thank you for watching this live
stream with me dion robon for the wall
street journal we'll be back on friday
at 1pm so please join us then and uh
yeah i look forward to seeing you there
and look forward to seeing you again
mondays and you know whatever day we do
this live stream thanks for tuning in
and i appreciate you